okay so let me talk a little bit about
why we are talking about transcriptomic
data
in the context of drug discovery drug
repurposing
and personalized medicine so as you know
bioinformatics plays a critical role
in modern drug discovery repurposing
biomarker screening
and design of personalized treatment
regimens
and so many industries and research labs
are actually seeking out
experts that are knowledgeable in onyx
data processing
analysis and integration and there are
many different
challenges as well as opportunities in
being able to
integrate analyze and turn this data
into a model that could be used to
design further experiments
now a lot of this is based on omics
data and the term omics actually means a
lot of different types of data
and so this program is going to be
focused on transcriptomic data
but the program that we are a part of
today is
covering several different elements of
data that i think are important to
understand
so one example is phenomics and this
means
phenotypic data that can include cell
morphology
the way that cells shape right different
cells have very different
shapes and they are dysregulated in
different ways we
can also talk about genomic data right
so the sequences
of nucleotides and amino acids typically
referred to
as genomic data epigenomic data which is
a field that has been growing
very fast since about 2007 2008
where we see an increase in the
appreciation of how
translation of sequences to mrna
and proteins is an important component
of
non-hereditary regulation of
genomic sequencing data and
finally what we will be focusing on in
this program
is the transcriptomic data and so this
program on transcriptomic data analysis
is an important part because it provides
a real in-depth view of how we can
use gene expression and isoform
expression
patterns for discovery of biomarkers
for understanding of drug targets and
for
being able to perform analysis
of drug function based on
expression of mrna in different forms
so in this program which is called
rna sequencing for drug discovery and
repurposing
we will look for how people use
transcriptomic data to link
targets to diseases validate these
targets
and explore their variation in the
natural
systems biology and so i think that this
really brings into the spotlight
this new era of drug discovery where
transcriptomics could be used for
discovery of
new compounds and complex molecules like
proteins
that can control disease through the
regulation of gene expression
that essentially mimic the mechanism by
which our bodies
exert regulatory control over a range of
normal and disease functions and so to
speak a little bit about
why next generation sequencing and what
this term means
and how we can use specifically this
kind of data
let me briefly talk about the history
behind next generation sequencing
and other forms of measurement for mrna
and this will help us see why we can
actually use
not just any type of mrna measurement
tool
but specifically next generation
sequencing
so as a method of measuring rna
translation transcriptomic studies can
help detect
mrna expression inside the cell as an
accurate alternative to membrane protein
expression
detection which allows for molecular
precision in diagnostics and even
development of
treatment based on molecular pathways so
what you can see here is the expression
of the her2
surface protein which could be a
measurement a detection of that protein
essentially tells us something
about the property of the cell and about
the
in the processes inside the cell or
subcellular
molecular processes that are so
important for understanding
of that tissue condition and potential
response to drug treatment so
when we think about our ability to
detect
such protein surfaces there are actually
several different techniques to do that
and uh before we get to rna sequencing
we can talk about
one of these technologies which is
microarray technologies
so the microarray technologies allow us
to hybridize
sequences of mrnas or actual transcripts
in these flow cells that then we can
extract rna from cells or tissues and
then see which ones
bind together to these uh small
sequences
to measure abundance of specific
molecules that we are interested in now
as opposed to microarray
next generation sequencing actually has
revolutionized the way that we can look
at transcriptomes because
they provide us with so many
novel insights about what's actually
going on
one we don't have to perform a
preparation technique that creates the
assay
we just measure all the mrna that is
present
inside the cell and then we can analyze
what kind of alternative splicing events
are happening so what types of
isoforms are being generated what types
of
genes are being expressed and then
how can we combine or look separately
at these two different types of data to
make informed decisions
about the types of samples that we are
looking at
so what we'll talk about in this program
is
our ability to leverage this kind of
big data and see the significance of
mrna expression in the context of
data integration which is really the
frontier
that drug discovery drug repurposing and
personalized treatment
deals with so
what's important here is that you will
find many
interesting and important biomedical
projects that can
leverage rna-seq data for diagnostics
and cancer biology understanding
for disease classification and patient
stratification which are so important
for clinical trials and understanding of
real patient populations that need to be
treated
as well as single cell and tissue
composition so we will be able to look
at
how single cell and different types of
immune cells different types of tissues
actually represent a heterogeneous
composition of cells with different
properties
that need to be deconvoluted for us to
be able to apply
meaningful drug discovery and screening
as well as biomarker and precision
medicine
targeting of novel treatments